[Music]
to ask you about something you tweeted
recently that I didn't understand you
tweeted no one sits on a stool like Rod
Stewart yes what's going on there what
do you talk about well I just I realized
that he he got he got to a point in his
career where he there's like there's a
point in certain people's careers where
they bring out a stool like at a certain
you know certain age there's a moment in
the night where Rod Stewart brings out
that stool and everybody just is like
yes the stool and he sits down and it's
like always to whatever and then
everyone's like yes and they know thou
the stool they want the stool because
they know that it's gonna lead to this
sense singers who do this or I I mean I
I think that comedians also I feel like
Cosby is that the stool point of his he
said yeah and he's you know now I feel
it's a guy I don't know what it is about
performers but it's like the the
wheelchair of the performing is the
stool this what no one wants to see a
singer a comedian come out and then sit
in a wheelchair yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah no one wants to see that no
and I think it must be substituted I
think it's just Rod Stewart gets tired
but we're or the songs too emotional for
him so he needs the-- he's tired but the
excuse that he uses is on to mmm the
audience now know it's like you know
Pavlovian they know stool me and you
know Cosby's got and I'm sure he does
you know three hours of material just
based on the stool and right you know
the zoo's got four legs so doggie your
what up you know I don't know but he
does so much you know he does like five
hours of yeah he's incredible he's it's
called stand-up but still an out he's on
the stool